three quarters of Democrats want to
nominate a fresh face for president in
2020 as public opinion polls show the
party veering sharply to the left all of
this is bad news of course for the
reanimated corpse of former future
president Hillary Clinton but it's great
news for Alexandria Ocasio Cortes the
wild-eyed fresh-faced socialist fraud
with wind between her ears then Lisa de
Pasquale will stop by to discuss these
youths in her new book the social
justice warrior handbook a practical
Survival Guide for snowflakes
Millennials and Generation Z because all
of nature is but art unknown to thee an
underestimated straight-shooting
American president meets with a Russian
dictator on this day in history
finally a British baby sentenced to
death in the United Kingdom is alive
today because this is America this is
America I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
in the spirit of communism and socialism
and to Alexandria ocasion Cortez I'm not
gonna do any ads today because money is
bad man
you know money is where I don't want to
make any money money is terrible I don't
want to keep the lights on it wouldn't
be cool if we could all just like hang
out and write poetry
so no ads today that's my that's my mark
for socialism because there's a really
scary scary statistics going around
about how Millennials have embraced
socialism and apparently like issuing
all education whatsoever and this is the
wave of the future this is the wave of
the Democratic Party future a major
difference between leftists and
conservatives is that leftists read Karl
Marx and conservatives understand Karl
Marx nowhere is this more evident than
this girl Alexandria Ocasio Cortez who
she went on the public affairs show on
PBS firing line it's the reboot of the
Bill Buckley show and this one is hosted
by Margaret Hoover and she just spewed
ignorance she kind of laughed about how
ignorant she is it's blithe ignorance
and she's a unrepentant radical
socialist the numbers of that are going
way way up it's really scary on this
question you know left us to read Marx
conservatives understand Marx here
enters Alexandria Ocasio Cortes talking
about unemployment I'm not the left
versus the right right now the economy
is going pretty strong right there's
roughly 4% unemployment 3.9 percent
unemployment do you think that
capitalism has failed to deliver for
working-class Americans or is no longer
the best vehicle for working-class
America well I think the numbers that
you just talked about is part of the
problem right because we look at these
figures and we say oh unemployment is
low everything is fine right well
unemployment is low because everyone has
two jobs unemployment is low because
people are working 60 70 80 hours a week
and can barely feed their kids and so I
do think that right now when we have
this no-holds-barred Wild West hyper
capitalism what that means is profit at
any cost
capitalism has not always existed in the
world and it will not always exist in
the work
where do I begin with that where this is
by the way I got to tell you this lady
is probably the Democrats best shot at
messaging in November because right now
everything is going so so well in every
area of Public Policy Foreign Affairs
domestic affairs but especially in the
economy and that's the undeniable part
right now the economy is booming we're
basically that we're the strongest
economy we've ever had the the Federal
Reserve is seeing more growth they're
observing more growth projecting more
growth the International Monetary Fund
is crediting Donald Trump's policies
with global economic growth not just
American economic growth the tax cuts
people are seeing that in their
paychecks unfortunately about 80% of
Americans use direct deposit so they're
not necessarily seeing the benefits of
tax reform in every single paycheck but
they are seeing it when April rolls
around they're also seeing it because
the corporate tax rate was slashed so
we're seeing just the the economy is
just roaring right now it's doing pretty
well also for the first time in over a
decade wages are rising wages have not
been rising and there are a number of
reasons for that a lot of economic
reasons some reasons with regarding with
regard to migration and immigration but
we're seeing wages rising pretty
significantly for the first time in a
long time so everything's going so well
and what is the Democrat answer the
socialist answer is don't believe your
lyin eyes good economies are bad up is
down war is peace that's what they're
saying how Orwellian this is the
Newspeak is you're saying oh yeah low
unemployment it's really really bad
because that means people are working
and workings is terrible I hate working
do you have a look I've done a lot in my
life to avoid working you know I the
only book I've ever written doesn't have
any words but I got to tell you working
is a good thing people feel better when
they're working God in the Garden of
Eden doesn't just say hey Adam loaf
around all day says you have to
cultivate the garden before the fall he
says you have to cultivate the garden
you have to name the beasts you have to
you know tend to this world that I've
given you you have dominion over and you
have to cultivate it working is good
it's when people retire they just like
wither away and die I'm not not all the
time people can enjoy retirement but
they have to be doing something if
you're you know it you can look if you
retire you can you know join a
non-profit you can volunteer
at the church you can see your family a
lot and sort of spend a lot of time with
them if you sit on a couch and watch TV
you're not gonna last very long people
are meant to work and this happened
during the Obamacare debates the
Democrats Nancy Pelosi said look one of
the reasons that people stay in their
jobs is to keep their health care but we
don't want that we don't want people to
feel like they have to work we want them
to be able to quit their jobs and
they'll have more time to write poetry
and walk through the woods and you know
just do it no that's bad people don't
like that idle hands are the devil's
playground you do have to work and it's
the only answer they have but by the way
the reason unemployment is low right now
is not because people have two jobs that
doesn't make any sense right but like
the eye that just she's pulling that out
of thin air because you know that people
are really really overworked right now
look the evidence is that wages are
going up there are more jobs than people
to fill them this is good this is a
great time to be an American worker best
time in a very long time but imagine how
removed she is from the real economic
circumstances of people on the ground
you know leftists socialists communists
like Alexandria Ocasio Cortes they're
ideologue who say who cares if the
economy is working in practice doesn't
work in theory does it work in theory
you know how removed she's trying to
portray herself as this you know
downtrodden hard worker from the Bronx
you know who grew up in dire poverty and
had no opportunities that's not true she
grew up a town away from where I did in
Westchester County she grew up in a more
affluent town in one of the most
affluent counties in the country and she
had all of those opportunities her
candidacy is premise taun this idea she
says people like me aren't supposed to
run for office
what affluent people who went to
expensive private colleges and got
extraordinarily good public education
they're not supposed to go that's who's
supposed to be a politician then either
people like me are really rich
privileged people or not you're cute
kidding me you the sort of sir even if
you grew up without a lot of money in
your family in in Westchester County
going to those schools what like I did -
we have some basically parallel stories
you still are so far be I mean you were
you were at the the crux of
in the United States which means and if
you're just born in the United States
you're at the height of privilege in the
world so it's this totally disingenuous
thing and her answer is no money's bad
that's basically her answer right that's
she saying no it's bad for people to you
know you don't they shouldn't work they
should get everything for free but then
here comes the best part of her of a
range review on this program the
Margaret Hoover show because it really
it really highlights what what these
young lefty Millennials are like here
she is talking about Israel Palestine I
also think that what people are starting
to see at least in in the occupation of
Palestine is just an increasing crisis
of humanitarian condition you use the
term the occupation of Palestine I think
it what I meant is like the the
settlement places where or Palestinians
are experiencing difficulties do you
think you can expand on that I am NOT
the expert geopolitics on this issue
this girl has a degree from an expensive
private university in international
relations she says I'm not an expert on
a basic question of foreign policy where
she's running for Congress she's almost
certainly going to win that seat for
Congress but that was her degree she's
got a call up bu and get a refund show
apparently Yorktown High School isn't as
good as we all thought it was
unbelievable it and it really by the way
I don't mean to just pick on her I
actually kind of feel bad for this girl
cuz she is so so profoundly ignorant and
sort of blithely ignorant and proudly
ignorant but you know this is a real
problem of education because she knows
the slogans Democrats know the slogans
they know the talking points she's
refers to the Israeli occupation of
Palestine can you can you tell us more
about that it's not like Margaret Hoover
was trying to get her it what can you
tell us more it's not a gotcha question
you know Jesus could you expand on that
and okay see of Cortez goes no no I
can't I don't know anything
next what pass we excuse me y'all pass I
think I'll pass on that question just
moves right along this is a trouble of a
millennial education because first of
all there's no country called Palestine
there's never
in a country called Palestine as I
mentioned on Fox this morning it's the
country to the east of Narnia and the
west of Wakanda it's not a country it's
just an ideological talking point but
the way that Millennials were educated
and I can really speak to this I went to
high school in the town over from where
she went to high school at the same time
were the same age I know a lady doesn't
tell her age but we she and I are the
same age and the way that we were
educated I don't I don't blame the
teachers I've had wonderful teachers the
curricula all across the country and
especially in New York focus on not
having students learn names dates facts
details what they focus on is broad
themes you don't need to know the facts
look you have an iphone you can always
look up the facts just know the broad
themes just know our ideological
position and don't look too closely into
those details because that might
contradict the position it's a real fear
it's a trouble in in education more
broadly over the last few decades which
is that people don't read the original
texts they read Howard Zinn talking
about the the framers and the founders
of you know they read these left-wing
ideologue and so they just get this sort
of glib talking points they don't know
the facts and then the moment that
someone says Oh tell me more about that
opinion she goes oh well I'm not an
expert and by the way she finishes that
clip she goes oh I'm not an expert on
this but I firmly believe and this is
like the most bothersome things that
Millennials do they say oh I didn't read
that book but here's what I think about
it oh I didn't see the movie but here's
what I think about it you know they're
frequently wrong but never in doubt they
have opinions on things that they don't
know anything about and what's a the
Ocasio Cortez is proudly ignorant
because she doesn't have humility what a
person who had any humility would say is
first of all someone running for office
should know should know about
israel-palestine they should know about
problems in the Middle East this is a
sort of basic aspect of international
relations and as someone who has a
degree in international relations
certainly should know about that but I
don't really blame her for being
ignorant people are ignorant all the
time it's the pride of it she says you
know I'd if you had humility you would
say I don't know about this and so I'm
gonna have to do some research and I'll
get back to you when I've thought about
this more she says well I don't know
anything about this but I'm pretty sure
that I'm right let me tell you you
should believe what I think that I think
even
I don't know anything that is a real
problem it's a crux of Millennials and
it is part of the reason by the way why
socialism is creeping in in such huge
numbers you know she she says these
things but this woman is a communist
she's a member of the Democrat
socialists of America
she says that capitalism won't be around
forever she doesn't know what capitalism
is capitalism is a word that was
invented in the 1820s and really
popularized in later in the 19th century
by by Marx and Engels and it's to refer
to economic freedom I I don't even
usually use the word capitalism because
I think it's it's a contrivance of
socialists it was invented by socialists
to criticize them so I know economic a
Pattaya ISM means economic freedom I use
economic freedom do you think people
should be able to use their money how
they want to use their money buy what
they want have have freedom have choice
if well then you're a capitalist if you
don't like that then you're
anti-capitalist she's anti-capitalist
people you know it's true capitalism
hasn't always existed freedom of
enterprise hasn't always existed that's
a bad thing it just means that certain
governments have abridged liberty and
certain governments have allowed liberty
and she says we need less Liberty I hope
we have less Liberty she uses these sort
of capital era communist rather talking
points of late-stage capitalism you know
the Democrats have always done this they
in the Bush years they would say we need
no war for oil you say when did we have
a war for oil the Oh Bush said when did
we get any oil how much oil did we get
uh Oh none we didn't get any oil we
should probably should have gotten some
oil and we didn't get me well is they
Bush lied people died is they Bush lied
huh yeah what do you lie about the
weapons and had it when it what was the
lie first of all Saddam Hussein did have
weapons of mass destruction second of
all all of the intelligence communities
around the world said that the weapons
existed it's not a lie even even if
there weren't which there were by the
way but even if there weren't weapons it
isn't a lie to lie you have to
intentionally not tell the truth
Oh Trump colluded with Russia what's
your evidence that Trump colluded with
Russia how that they just know the
slogans and it's really sad but right
now among these Millennials the
Millennials broadly not
just Democrats half of Millennials
identify as socialists according to some
new polls that is horrifying
the Democratic socialists of America
which had just 5,000 members less than
two years ago 2016 they had 5,000
members 2018 fast forward two years that
number has gone up Eightfold to 40,000
members that is a terrifying statistic
it's gone up eight times in just two
years that momentum isn't going to stop
part of it is that Millennials don't
remember communism they were born as
Cortez and and I were both you know in
the as the Berlin Wall was falling down
and because they were uneducated they
think history begins when they were born
you know they don't they don't even the
ones who have studied history haven't
really studied history broadly they've
studied people polemicists writing about
history like Howard Zinn and the
Democrats have moved very far to the
left here we're gonna get to ELISA de
Pasquale in a second because she's the
expert on these millennial sjw's but
just some scary statistics the the
Democrats had moved far to the left
according to Pew a study that came out a
Pew Research last year the parties have
moved apart from one another but most of
that movement the vast majority of that
movement is Democrats moving to the left
the GOP hasn't moved that much further
to the right it's the Democrats moving
to the left seventy-one percent of
Democrats right now believe that we
should go into debt to increase welfare
spending spend money that we don't have
borrow money from China to just dole it
out to the poor and redistribute wealth
that's that's up 17 percentage points in
just six years the GOP has moved just
one percentage point on this issue it's
dropped down just 1% Democrats have
moved 17 percentage points to the left
in 1994 the question was asked by pew do
immigrants strengthen the country
overall are they or are they aboon to
the country the parties basically were
in agreement Democrats said 32% yes GOP
said 30% yes
now the GOP has actually moved in that
direction to 42% Democrats have way more
than doubled it's up one and a half
times on that question 84% of Democrats
say yes immigrants are a spoon to the
country that's a huge divergence on the
question is racial discrimination the
main reason the blacks can't get ahead
the main reason not that does it exist
at all not are there ISIL
is racial discrimination the main reason
that some black people can't get ahead
that number when Democrats were asked
that question in 2010 not that long ago
28 percent said yes
now today 64 percent say yes the
question basic questions a political
philosophy is religion required for
morality the Democrat no answer is up 13
percentage points just since 2011 this
is these numbers are moving way way
faster than anyone would expect that
this is a bad sign and it's having some
negative consequences because they're
appointing these sort of witless people
who haven't ever studied the things that
they're talking about they don't know
anything that they're talking about
their radical leftists and some people
are trying to pump the brakes now you
know leading Democrats are realizing
this here's Barack Obama just today or
yesterday trying to pump the brakes on
all of this but democracy demands they
were able also to get inside the reality
of people who are different than us so
we can understand their point of view
maybe we can change their minds but
maybe they'll change ours and you can't
do this if you just out of hand
disregard what your opponents have to
say from the start and you can't do it
if you insist that those who aren't like
you because they're white or because
they're male that somehow there's no way
they can understand what I'm feeling but
somehow they lacked standing to speak on
certain matters who's that guy does
anyone can anyone recognize that guy cuz
he looks like Barack Obama but he sounds
like the opposite of Barack Obama either
this is being reported he just gave this
speech if it was a speech about nelson
mandela and it's being reported obama
issues stern rebuke to trump no obama
issues a stern rebuke to obama he's
criticizing his own the tone that he set
in the White House for the past eight
years or for the eight years that he was
president you know he's he's talking
about the politics of fear resentment
retrenchment this is the guy who said
I'm gonna fundamentally transform
America I'm gonna get rid of all those
bitter clingers those those rubes who
cling to their guns and religion he was
he painted the White House rainbow
colors as a rebuke to people who
or the Constitution in a traditional
view of marriage he said that those in
power seek to undermine every
institution that gives democracy meaning
this is the guy undermining institutions
he went up on and gave the State of the
Union and he he tried he insulted the
Supreme Court right to their faces when
they couldn't respond to it he was he
was utterly undermining the the Supreme
Court he was the one who said that his
surrogate said that Republican
Congressmen were terrorists he said he's
gonna roll over Congress because he has
a pen and a phone this is the guy
undermining institutions it's outrageous
this is a guy politicizing the IRS to
attack his political opponents
politicizing it appears the FBI to
attack and investigate his political
opponents and this
where was this Barack Obama in 2012 this
guy's vice president not not just
running mate sitting vice president said
that the Republican nominee was trying
to put black people back in Chains
that's what he said
he said the Trayvon Martin guy who was
killed in a in a sort of cloud of
mystery but whom we know was viciously
beating the guy who killed him beating
his head against the pavement we used we
saw photos of the the injuries he said
oh that he could have been my son what
do you mean he could have been your son
because he's black do all play Barack
Obama saying all black people look alike
basically it's outrageous
he doesn't really wouldn't have been
Barack Obama's son he doesn't doesn't
look like him either you know who
attacks the Cambridge police because of
a local affair you know it this is the
guy it's too little too late man you let
you let this loose you opened up
Pandora's box and now you you're reaping
the Alexandria Cortes Ocasio Cortez's
because of it you know the the
Democratic Party is is now in the grip
of these guys and this is why we've got
to get to the expert you know they're in
the grip of these aggrieved social
justice warrior entitled lightly
educated Millennials and the expert of
this the author to help us understand of
the of the social justice warrior
Handbook is ELISA de Pasquale a
practical survival guide for snowflakes
Millennials and generations II Lisa
thank you for being here hi there
thanks for having me I'm so glad to not
only be one degree away from Tom Arnold
that's I'm really a
the far degraded Kevin Bacon pivot point
here you know just bringing us all tom
has been tweeting me a lot today because
of the apparent evidence that President
Trump is now a Russian asset do you
think it's an open-and-shut case isn't
it the Trump is a Russian asset yeah I
mean I you know we knew that in October
2016 right you know it's it's funny
because he Tom tweeted me today said see
are you finally going to apologize and
admit the Trump's of Russian asset I
said you know the fact that he took that
soccer ball and threw it off the stage
like a hot potato that's how I know that
President Trump is a red-blooded
American and but I am worried about the
future of the country in one because I
look at people like Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes and also because I read your book
before we begin I have to say I'm seeing
some a little bit of plagiarism in here
Lisa from another yeah employees I
missed a whole chapter
I took word-for-word from your book it's
really at least you abridged it though
it's only about 10 or 15 pages in there
of absolutely well that's it's the one
book where you cannot read it and be an
expert I you know my first question
because I really did enjoy the book and
I encourage people to go out there and
buy it and read it it's really funny
what is it with these guys what is it
with this generation we beat up on
Millennials all the time and I want to
do it some more
what's their problem I think part of it
is actually kind of a lack of culture I
mean I'm um
Generation X I know I like super young
but I'm 41 and you know what lady
doesn't tell her age as I always pointed
out that I'm Alexandria's age too
yeah I mean I don't mind saying it
because I'd rather be called Gen X and
fair point maybe I'm gonna be trans
ageist I'm gonna be 41 here yeah you
identify as a gen Xer but I think part
of it is looking for some sort of
culture and of their own and they do
that I think by separating themselves
and by creating their own rules you know
for instance appropriation things like
that I mean I'm appropriating Mexican
culture I guess
and just sort of setting up their own
their own rules I mean you can go into a
hot topic and you don't see their own
bands you see you know 70s and 80s 60s
70s and 80s bands and there's just sort
of a generation loss because as far as
their knowledge like you said history
begins the day they were born but as as
as culture I don't think they really
have it I mean they don't have the stuff
that we identify so much and part of
that is because there are so many niches
I mean there's not you know the one TV
show that they all sat down and watched
as kids like like we did right which
which was Nick at Nite and that's why I
identify as a 75 year old at this point
the I think you've you hit on it because
it isn't just that they're poorly
educated because and I think there is a
real problem of Education for the
millennial generation but people can
always read books you can always try to
ameliorate that the issue is the lack of
culture and those are different things
you know they don't a couple generations
ago you could play people excerpts of
classical music you could reference
certain great books or novels you could
reference certain movies and people
would get it there was a sense of
cultural idioms that I think now just
don't exist why is that and is there any
way to get that back yeah I mean I don't
know I mean I think that's why things
like Blazing Saddles were we're we're
okay
because people didn't separate
themselves so badly that they didn't
know what their black friends or
Hispanic friends or or other friends
would think if they were caught watching
it they were already part of a big group
and they didn't have to feel like they
were being judged or that people didn't
know who they were you know based on you
know telling jokes are telling lines
from from a movie and now part of it is
also just that they're so willing to put
so much of their lives out there you
know on Twitter on Instagram or whatever
the kids are using snapchat yeah use
MySpace yeah yeah Facebook that it's the
culture I think pushing back but you
know what's interesting is you had
mentioned the poll before about so
ilysm but when you ask them individual
issues like well do you think that you
should be able to use apps like uber and
an Rover and things like that
I'm on individual issues they're more
you know capitalist or economic they
support economic freedom but in general
they say they support socialism and so I
don't know what the the the overlap is
but on the individual issues they do
support economic freedom but that's
where you go back to the education in
that they don't know that they don't
support socialism yeah and they just
think it sounds good it's just you know
they have a younger voice telling them
that it does the issue is the is the
Blyth in the blithe ignorance you know
this sort of carefreeness this cavalier
ignorant the we're and I blame I guess
in part the not just the education in
the lack of culture but the self-esteem
movement too because they've always been
told they're so so special and
everything they do is great and they're
they can do whatever they want to do and
they're gonna be wonderful and that you
know I'm just on a very basic level that
isn't true you know that that just isn't
the case I played Little League baseball
for eight years and I leaned into
pitches because I like Don Baylor I mean
I was a pretty good you know I was
pretty good at getting on base but I
couldn't hit that ball and I have eight
trophies from it I have eight
participation trophies and then that the
the what we were always told is that
when the Millennials get into the real
world the real world is going to hit
them like a freight train and they're
gonna grow up but when you look around I
don't see that happening I see people
like Alexandria court Ocasio Cortes
going on TV and saying oh yeah I guess I
don't know that very important issue
ahaha posh posh posh I'm gonna do to do
I'm just gonna go right to Congress are
they just gonna be able to be ouch kids
forever I mean so many of them are
living with their parents so many of
them are not paying bills every
millennial is on their parents cellphone
plan I mean they're gonna they're gonna
have like grandchildren before they get
off their parents cellphone plan okay
that's I think the workaround that they
found and that's like a big topic and
the social justice warrior Handbook is
they'll work around of living with their
parents and then now they have like a
dull day camps or summer camps they have
I mean the
that I can't stand as adulting you know
like I can't don't today they use it as
a verb yeah I have to adult today
because I have to pay my bills like I
don't even think about it as you know
behavior that's optional and there's you
know to me it was never optional whether
or not to have cell phone plans I mean
part of it might be because when I was I
get moved out of the house at 18
so things were barely a thing so I don't
think they had family plans but I think
they found a way and that's to prolong
this adolescence as long as possible you
know it used to be I mean kind of the
cutoff was 26 when you started with the
healthcare plan right and then now it's
like 30 and then there's kind of no age
on on cell phones and then they're
creating all this adult type of behavior
like where you can go places and have
naptime you can go to a summer camp
yeah the coloring books adult coloring
books it's all coloring books which
there's an activity and I actually call
it a dream book because I think workbook
is a little too demanding
that's right so here's the dream book
right here at section 4 yep it's pretty
yeah it's a dream you don't want to you
can't work you don't want to work no no
that that's right that mean that's
absolutely right and I I do worry that
there's you know I guess it's just as
with the ignorance just as with the
uncultured
it's the blitheness of it all they they
are cavalier about their parents paying
for their lifestyle their cavalier about
not working they're cavalier about not
having responsibility and and not
knowing and it you know I mean there it
even as a young man you know if right
when I turned 18 you know I or 20 or
whatever because everyone's on their
parents cell phone plan but I said like
I've got to pay I've got to pay for this
or I feel weird I like it's nice to not
have to pay but you but there's this
kind of anxiety that comes to and you
think I can't I could never live in my
father's house as a 24 year old I'd feel
weird about I wouldn't
to do that but there are so many
Millennials who who do want to do that
how what is that psychology like I mean
where does that come from and is there
any hope to fix it I think you know I
part of me doesn't just blame
Millennials or our younger like I guess
Gen Z part of it I think is the Boomers
and that's because they've been so
helpful I mean these are like the
original helicopter parents right that
wanted their kids to stay at home I mean
it's like the smother on on the
Goldbergs
who doesn't want the babies to leave the
nest so I think they hold some of the
blame but now they're getting older
they're wanting to retire and they're
looking and they're like we'll wait my
kids still here you know I'm ready to
move to Costa Rica but I can't get the
kid out of the house right I mean
they've been doing ads based on those
things there's an realtor ad that's but
that's basically around that concept and
you have to think if they're doing ads
based on these concepts they're not
foreign to a lot of people I mean these
are real issues that that people are
dealing with so to me they hold some
blame and in prolonging this adolescence
and I think that goes back to the
culture and you have to make it less
accepting with the culture that you know
if you're embarrassed to tell people you
know I live at home if you're
embarrassed to tell a date do you want
to come back to my parents place and
then I think at that point it was what
you're gonna start seeing the culture
change yeah yeah that is a shame you've
got it yeah you need because now
Millennials they're so afraid of shame
they say stop body shaming stop age
shaming stop jawed they do all this
shaming yeah you need a little shame man
the shame is a good thing shame well I
really enjoyed the book I encourage
people to go get it the social justice
warrior handbook a practical guide for
snowflakes Millennials and Generation Z
I also do want to quote I really like
Nick Searcy's blurb on it
Nick Searcy's a friend of the show he
comes and hangs out with us sometimes
and he said when it comes to political
advice you should only listen to
Hollywood actors like me but if I'm
unavailable this book will do
really and and you've got you've got
some great endorsements here you've got
an Coulter really recommends that you
know seriously a number of other people
and now a blank book author right then
perhaps the most entitled author ever
there has been also really recommends
that go out there and get it where can
people find you Lisa they can find the
book on Amazon they can find me on
Twitter at at Lisa de P and the website
for the book is sjw handbook com really
good Lisa thank you for being here Lisa
de Pasquale we'll have to have you back
and talk again yes for sure thanks
okay we've got a lot more to get to
today we've got to get to two segments
this is America and I'll probably do a
little sync do the dance and everything
hey you know and then we'll also have to
get to this day in history because there
is just weird coincidence it's real
Providence perhaps that the Trump
Helsinki summit with a Russian dictator
coincides with the historical
anniversary of the Potsdam Conference
when another straightforward American
president met with a Russian dictator
we'll get to that and we'll get to a
great story on this day in America or
the the stay in America this is America
where we talk about really the the
wonders of capitalism and free
enterprise and freedom of movement that
saved a poor little British baby before
that I have to say goodbye to you I have
to I have to get real capitalist now I
was communist at the top of the show and
I skipped the ad but now we get real
capitalists give me your money keep my
lights on let me start adulting and pay
my own bills go to daily wired.com right
now subscribe do it it's 10 bucks a
month $100 for annual membership and you
get a lot when you subscribe you get me
you get the end were Clavin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show get to ask
questions in the mailbag you get no ads
on the website you have to ask questions
in the conversation you get I don't know
like a bunch of cool stuff and most
importantly you get the leftist years
tumblr when Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
goes on TV and talks about fictional
countries and the end of capitalism and
all of that and Democrats like like good
electoral Democrats smart politician
Democrats like you know Barack Obama or
the Clintons right they they look and
they say no no no no don't say that
stuff no don't let them know what we
really want to do now oh no now they're
not gonna lose oh is that good go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back with
this is America and this day in history
we're back so let's begin with this is
America we're running late as per huge
as perused when I'm adult I gotta start
adulting so I can keep my schedule
properly but on on this segment of this
is America I got to talk about baby
Oliver this is a great story only in
America would this be true
so you remember you've heard these
stories in the UK of little Alfie Evans
he was the baby that the UK authorities
the National Health Service said he's
got this disease there's no way that
he's going to live the parents said
we'll let let us take him to look for
treatment elsewhere they said absolutely
not we own your baby you're not allowed
to do it I mean even you've got the Pope
trying to intervene you've got the the
Italian government offering babies like
Alfie Evans or Charlie guard but
citizenship so that they can come there
and get get help they need and this and
no you're not gonna do with this baby
has to die we are gonna make this baby
die and he's gonna die with dignity
that's the new euphemism they use when
they refuse people the Liberty to try to
care for their own children and try to
save their own children so this baby
baby Oliver was diagnosed with cardiac
fibroma
which is an exceedingly rare affliction
of the heart where he had this huge
tumor in his heart little baby Oliver as
the huge tumor and the the doctors there
had never seen anything like this a lot
of them didn't know what it was didn't
know what it could be and all of the
doctors in the UK said we can't treat it
the only way that we can try to save his
life is with a heart transplant but the
trouble is is as in all socialistic
systems there are long waiting lines and
for for a baby it's virtually impossible
most likely the baby would have just
died waiting to get a heart transplant
it would have been very very risky
they said this tumor just cannot be
removed sorry your kid is gonna die
there's nothing you can do about it so
what happens the parents say can we look
elsewhere in the UK and National Health
Service and it's typical way says no
sorry no way no no we're not gonna pay
for anything we're not gonna let you
look no your kids probably gonna die
and so the Boston Children's Hospital
hears about this and they post and they
say we can help I know that you British
socialist health care system you can't
help but we can help because we because
of our free enterprise we have far
better
care more innovative care and we're and
we're gonna allow you to do it we're
gonna give you the freedom to try to pay
for your your kid to live and so the
National Health Service in the UK hears
about this and what do they do they say
nope we're not gonna pay for that we're
not gonna pay to transport we're not
gonna send any doctors nope sorry the
kid has to die die with dignity he's got
to die all that do you know all that
dignity of death and then so dignified
so the parents started a fundraiser and
they raised almost all of the money that
was needed to do it themselves and I
think because of all the bad press the
NHS has recently received they finally
caved on this they said oh yes sure oh
you wanted to save your kid oh yeah no
we're we want you that's good we do that
so what about for the last year you've
been letting those other kids die and
refusing to let their parents oh no that
would know we love saving kids okay so
they finally cave once there's enough
publicity enough money raised and they
even sent a couple doctors to go with
the kid and the at the Boston Hospital
Boston Children's Hospital they said
look it's a huge tumor it's really where
we don't know if we can remove the whole
thing do our best what did they do
because this is America they removed the
whole tumor they removed the whole thing
in this miraculous surgery they were
sure everybody was shocked that this
could happen and now that kid gets to
live which is a very good thing only in
America could that happen not in the
United Kingdom not elsewhere in the
world and why though why wish alexandria
Ocasio Cortez would watch my show so
that you could learn these wonderful
things about the the capitalist system
she sewed derides
it's because we have freedom and freedom
you know it is true that freedom allows
people to risk things you can in a in a
free enterprise system you have the
right to lose your own money you have
the right to make trouble for yourself
but you also have the right to be Tam
ingenuity and to save yourself and to
save your kids and the the UK they're
focusing on death with dignity these are
the ghouls who want to chip
fundamentally change the medical
profession from only caring for people
in in helping people and helping to save
people to killing them to assisted
suicide to killing people because death
is better than life it's an anti-life
movement and with death and with dignity
means that you don't value life in
America we have a life with dignity we
say you can live with dignity
when you dot look we're all headed for
the same place we're all gonna have our
bodies turn to worm food at some point
but not today you can live with dignity
and there's another aspect of this which
is economic and it's the scarcity
mindset and the abundance mindset in
socialistic countries and economies and
societies they have a scarcity mindset
there's a pie and it's this big and
everyone's gonna get some of that pie
and that's all there is the abundance
mindset is baked more pie the pie can
grow economies are not static societies
are not static you can have innovation
you can have abundance you can grow and
grow and grow and you don't have that I
mean Margaret Thatcher spelled it out
very well he said the Socialists they
just want to reduce economic inequality
even if everybody is lower they want the
difference to be down here rather than
have some more inequality but everybody
is doing much much better you know it's
not the economy is not just a pie you
can have abundance and you can say yes
we can do it that is the outlook because
socialism I I think Winston Churchill
I'm gonna paraphrase this because I'm
not gonna get the quote right but it's a
philosophy of failure and the gospel of
envy you know it's this it's just this
very dour down looking scarce decrepit
philosophy it's and it's a 200 year old
philosophy 150 year old philosophy it's
not there's nothing new about it there's
nothing innovative but abundance and
innovation that's always that the
American spirit and it's in it we see
evidence of this we see wonderful
example because it saved a British
babies life very good stuff before I let
you all go today we got a talk also in
this day in history because all of
nature is but art unknown today in
chance direction which thou canst not
see everyone's talking about Russia and
you know I've got Tom Arnold tweeting at
me and saying that Trump's a traitor
because he made some perhaps loose
comments yesterday at a press conference
that it changes practically nothing
about American foreign policy and he did
it accomplished a few important things
too but on this day in history in 1945
President Truman met at the Potsdam
Conference it was the big three he met
Winston Churchill was there and also
Joseph Stalin the this you know the the
world with the worst dictator ever one
of the worst dictators and the Soviet
dictator so as strange coincidence who
knows if it was planned that way it's
hard for me to imagine that it wasn't
planned with some sense
of the calendar but they met there and
Truman and Trump have some similarities
you know they're both can both
underestimated both considered kind of
stupid they came from industries that
are not traditionally political a lot of
people think that they were - that they
talked to straight in a too
straightforward a manner you know
they're too blunt and what happens at
that conference by the way is that
Truman mentioned to Stalin he said you
know we've got this new bomb that's much
more destructive than any bomb we've
ever had and it's reported differently
by different people but he told Stalin
about the bomb that they were about to
use they sort of agonized over this they
said should we surprise the Soviets and
just use the bomb on the Japanese and
end this war and they'll learn about it
when we blow it up or do we want to give
them a heads up because they're our
allies in this war they ultimately
decided on the ladder but from everyone
in attendance Churchill said this
Anthony Eden said this Truman said this
everyone said that Stalin didn't really
react he said oh that's good you got a
good bomb use it against the Japanese
and the war and it was only later on
that some of the Russian ministers said
oh yes Stalin played it very cool in the
moment but he immediately got down that
night and said we've got to start
building this or bomb faster we've got
to catch up with them what we what we do
know though is that they the event the
historical ramifications of that event
only became clear much later you know
when you're dealing it's not like these
are straightforward and negotiations and
summits when you're dealing with these
people you know the Soviet dictators are
killers they're sharks and what we think
is the obvious way to deal with them
it's not always the obvious way and and
the ramifications will be clear later on
so everyone is freaking out over this
Trump press conference with Putin what
we really need to do is pump the brakes
and see what happens you know because
it's these things are not clear in the
moment they'll become clear over time
Putin said I don't trust Trump Trump
doesn't trust me what will come of this
will be clear over time are we allowed
to are we going to work with the
Russians are we going to share some
strategic interests or are we going to
have just an acrimonious eight years and
then another eight years at the Penn's
administration and then who know it'll
go on and on and on are we what are we
going to have everybody take a breather
it's okay these this has happened before
that the United States didn't fall apart
yesterday it's alright so he's going
just fine there was a good NATO summit
we got a lot of good progress there yeah
as the New York Times admits president
Trump accomplished much of what Barack
Obama tried to accomplish and failed to
accomplish and as the you know the
Democrats were always pushing for that
Russian reset the Bush administration
was pushing to reset relations with
Russia and get out on a good foot
you know george w bush said i saw
vladimir putin's soul in his eyes and
probably dark and black place and in
blender Putin's ole he's just like the
fires of hell glowing behind them and
you know President Trump goes there and
he says oh yeah you know look we we're a
little bit to blame to for for the the
problems in the relationship between the
US and Russia these are just things that
people say we'll see how that
relationship goes moving forward but ah
take a breather you know on this point
to another coincidence on this day in
history in 1776 Congress learned that
the the British General Howe had offered
a peace deal to General Washington you
know the British had landed Washington
had moved his troops from Boston down to
New York the British could you know
ready to wipe them out but General Howe
said you know we'll we'll just try to
negotiate some peace and we'll let the
colonies come back in and no harm no
foul and he sent an emissary to
Washington and Washington read the
letter in the letter did not begin with
the word general didn't say General
Washington he wouldn't address him as
general and Washington was so insulted
by this he sent them packing he ripped
it up he said not a chance and this is a
little just a little warning to add here
words do matter words really do matter
in international affairs certainly and
in politics you know did that break or
video on it the words really really
matter speech is the essential human Act
and the words that use matter so I you
know all in all as I say it take a
breather it doesn't everything is fine
in American foreign relations and and
with Russia it is worth pointing out to
to defend some of the critics of that
press conference yesterday the words do
really matter one has to be pretty
careful with what they say because
speech is the political act it's the
human Act
and so you know if I I think that press
conference yesterday was just great and
it was like four words from being really
good you know and a few words just
really left a bad taste in people's
mouths one does have to be careful
because words when we're negotiating
when we're talking like loose people
words can be used really Catholic in a
Cavalier way but you've you've got to be
precise about what you're saying so that
there's not not a lot of confusion on
that point I hope I haven't confused you
on that point
come back tomorrow get your mailbag
questions in we're gonna do that on
Thursday we've got some great guests we
have like too many great guests right
now so I've got to figure out we did a
pre tape interview with my priest father
rut ler so maybe maybe we'll try to get
that to you soon
because man if you think I'm right wing
you got to listen to my yesterday really
talk about the opposite where we've
owned that Millennials are uncultured
and uneducated this guy has read every
single book ever and it's the most
cultured man I know so we'll get that to
you and some other great interviews
coming up to so tune in in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
board senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you